you
[Music]
hi I'm Regina hurt slinger call me
Reggie everybody calls me Reggie I'm a
professor at the Harvard Business School
and I've been teaching a course on how
to innovate in healthcare for about 30
years and I've had thousands of
graduates from all over the world I'm so
proud of them
many of them have innovated healthcare
but there's still so much opportunity so
health care is gigantic it's about three
trillion dollars in the u.s. so what is
three trillion dollars it's so can
imagine what that is so that's the size
of the GDP of China that's just the US
healthcare system and the rest of the
world is just about as big so six
trillion dollars six trillion dollars of
waste it is among the most wasteful
sectors in the world in fact health care
has negative labor productivity what
that means in English is every extra
dollar or euro that you're sticking to
healthcare diminishes the GDP certainly
not what we want
then it's quality who knows totally
reputational so when you go to the store
and you buy a yogurt you take this
little package of yogurt and you know so
much about the yogurt first of all you
know its price do you know the price of
anything and the health care very much
doubt it
secondly you know a lot about the
quality of the yogurt how much calcium
does it have how many calories does it
have how much protein does it have so
you know pretty much what you want to
know about the yogurt how about when you
go to your doctor how about if you're
really sick and you need a mastectomy or
if you
and you need a prostatectomy what do you
know you don't know anything so quality
is a problem don't get me wrong we've
got great doctors we've got great
hospitals
we've got great technology but how do we
know how great they are everybody can be
great so this another problem in health
care and isn't it ironic I know
everything I want to know about a
trivial purchase like my yogurt but when
comes to my health care I don't know any
third problem is access so even in the
United States the richest country in the
world currently as I speak out of our
330 million people we have 50 million
people who don't have health insurance
and even if our health care reform law
kicks in we'll still have 20 million
people without health insurance all over
the world and people lack health
insurance in fact the Chinese are great
sailors and every every good thing has a
bad thing associated with it good thing
they say bad thing they don't spend
their money most economies rely on
consumption to keep the economy going
and when the Chinese don't spend money
but save money ironically they dampen
the economy so why are they such great
savers they don't have health insurance
and they're worried that if they get
sick how will they pay for and so they
they say so we have a lot of uninsured
many developing countries have virtually
no health insurance and even countries
that allegedly have health insurance
don't really have health insurance so if
your
in the UK everybody has health insurance
does everybody have equal access to care
no if you're poor if you Donna certif if
you don't look like you're going to sue
if you're not connected if your uncle or
your aunt isn't a doctor or nurse you go
to the back of the line now I've got to
give the people in the UK a lot of
credit they keep studying this problem
most governments would bury it and say
no problem but they keep studying it and
decade after decade just a mere fact of
having insurance doesn't mean you have
access so lots of the opportunities
we've got to control the costs of health
care
virtually every developed country in the
world as the GDP grows like this the
cost of health care grows like that and
because it has negative productivity
that's not good for the GDP we've got
issues with quality namely we don't know
how good it is and then thirdly we have
even with countries that have health
insurance for everybody doesn't really
mean everybody it means if you look like
you're going to sue if you know somebody
in the health care system you get
different kind of treatment from people
who don't know that these are all
problems but there are all opportunities
opportunities to make health care
cheaper opportunities to standardize and
measure the quality of health care
opportunities to increase access so that
everybody can access the same quality of
care so I hear about people with ideas
about how to make it better
day-in day-out tons of ideas
telemedicine new drugs new devices new
computer programs new ways of delivering
care tablets so that people who have
elder loved ones can write down all the
information concierge medicine kinds of
offerings so she mean appointments you
don't have to stand on the line forever
on the phone you can do it via your PC
ideas ideas ideas but you know what most
of these ideas never come to fruition
and if they do many of them all too many
of them fail so here's what we're going
to do we're going to look at a way of
analyzing whether an innovation is
likely to succeed or likely to fail and
we're going to do this with an analytic
framework and then once we've determined
whether an innovation is likely to
succeed we're going to look at the
elements of the business model that make
it a really viable business now when I
say business I don't mean for profit I
mean any kind of entrepreneurial venture
whether it's for-profit nonprofit
governmental we're going to say does
this thing have legs we're going to
separate the wheat from the chaff and
then once we've got the wheat there
we're going to look at the elements that
make it successful so I have a framework
that has nine steps in it and we're
going to systematically go through these
nine steps and then if you hang in there
with me and more power to you if you do
we're going to go through a number of
studies of different kinds of
entrepreneurial healthcare ventures and
we're going to keep applying this
framework this analytic framework can we
tell the winners from the losers and
from the winners what are the key
elements that need to be there in order
to make them successful so we're going
to study this with these different case
studies and their global there are all
entrepreneurial they cover different
kinds of innovations and then we have
videos of the CEOs of these companies
these people who were the key movers and
shakers and we've interviewed them and
you're gonna learn how they got to where
they got what makes for an entrepreneur
and when you see these people you'll see
they they look like everybody else so
what is it that made them an
entrepreneur and then secondly in their
sector what do they think are the next
great ideas for innovation I pay a lot
of attention to this these are not only
smart people but they've walked the talk
they've really done it so every case
study says what should he or she do what
should this entrepreneur do we're going
to explore what we think they should do
and they're gonna tell us what they
actually did